Hey,
what's going on is bill burn is time for
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 28th,
2016 and I'm doing on November 29th
at Tuesday. What's going on? How, why?
Yeah. Um, I am okay. Case. You
were wondering. I got a little,
uh,
I don't know.
I got a little s I've been fighting off
this cough for like two fucking weeks.
Who's kidding? Who? Right.
And I, uh, you know,
I was fighting off and it was
getting worse and he kept going.
Why don't you take some medicine? Why did
I say take, take some of this new youth,
the next, all right.
Holy Shit. Half fucking,
my hat's off to anybody that can get
fucking drunk off their, that stuff.
Jesus Christ.
That's like peppermint Schnapps
Times fucking 20. Really?
It's Musinex. It's like schnapps
on steroids. It's just, you know,
one of the,
you know,
the other ones of these dumb champ
challenges like the mannequin challenge.
I don't understand.
What is the challenge?
Just hold still has somebody
pans around the room.
That's a fucking challenge. How the fuck
did we go from faking a lunar landing,
faking that,
faking out the whole fucking Russians.
And they got so freaked out that day day
when they went on a hissy fit for the
next fucking 30 years before they finally
went broke. Right in the early nineties
cause we, we accepted the challenge
of the faking of the lunar land.
Maybe we even got there, the Lunar Lander
Atlantic challenge. Now we're fucking,
oh, the mannequin. Oh, planking. Yeah.
I lay face down and somebody
takes a picture of me.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I don't know what the
f you know what it is,
is he's fucking Goddamn cuts young people
these days, you know, no offense, right?
God blushes.
Let's say fucking spend their whole
lives with these fucking reality,
virtual reality. God Damn things on
their head. They're playing video games.
They don't have any skills to second,
you take the fucking laptop,
you take the fucking laser tag thing,
the pink gun,
whatever the fuck technology
is. The thing that, you know,
that new thing that they're trying to
get old people into the virtual reality,
like, like live in a fucking
life is it isn't enough.
Like I want to leave this
fucking world. Really. You
wrote of both through the fucking
canal. You haven't done shit. All right,
so this is the deal. They don't fucking
know how to fucking do anything.
This is such an old man rent not to do
anything that just fucking literally
laying face down in the road, you know,
and somebody takes a picture is, is this,
it's epic. It's fucking
epic. Now granted in the 70s,
they did have pet rock, so I might be
full of Shit. But you know what it is,
the great thing about being
old is you lack perspective.
When you talk about anything new, you're
just like, that's different. It scares me.
Um, I don't get the mannequin
challenge. I don't, you know,
and that, that was like
the hell. So had the, uh,
whatever the Harlem shake was initially
it was a dance and then it was just that
stupid youtube. They, the ice
bucket challenge, all of that shit.
You know, if your instincts
aren't immediately to not
be part of the group. Um,
I don't know what that says about you.
I don't want it says about me that I
immediately ice buck or everybody's doing
it.
Well then fucking I'm not doing it.
Anti social sick. Freckled headed bald
current. What's wrong with you today?
Hang on a second.
Rico law.
Yeah. So I've been fighting this fucking
thing off. You know, I have a bad feeling.
It might be one the cigar that I
got that there's something in there,
some sort of bacteria because I was fine.
And then I smoked with first he on his
birthday and then I smoked with Bobby
Kelly had fucking comics come
home back to back nights.
And then I just had this fucking
cough. You know, it's Nike Inhale,
the Goddamn things. It's not like
I smoked one every fucking day.
I smoke one like once every two weeks or
they've been a little bit of a bender.
Okay. Um, so anyways, so Sunday night,
you know, it's been a good 15 days
since I smoked. All right. I'll smoke.
Another one went down with my buddy.
We watched the Broncos chiefs game,
arguably the greatest Sunday
night football game ever.
I lost track of how many fucking
lead changes there were. Um,
just, you know, and I wasn't drinking.
I haven't drank since thanksgiving.
I kind of bottomed out thanksgiving.
Right. You know, a speck.
I had a great thanksgiving, by the
way. Great fucking thanksgiving. Um,
we ended up day. Talk about that
already. I think I already did.
Maybe it didn't. I don't remember. Or I
started Taco. I hadn't gone to it yet.
That's right. That's what
it was. Listen to this shit.
We went to somebody else's for
Thanksgiving and everything
was fucking delicious.
Every side was fucking not only delicious.
It was a home run set. Best thanksgiving
I've had since I've been a kid.
When I eat my mom, my parent's
house, you know, my mother cooked.
So it just automatically taste right.
Cause that's the only thanksgiving,
you know. Right. But at once you move out,
you're eating other people's
food and no matter what,
it's always a little bit different.
It's not quite the same.
You get that feeling of, fuck, it's over.
I have to pay rent now I'm
going to get old, right?
I'm going to be that person.
What happened to him and then I fucking
die and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
and all that bullshit. Right? So anyways,
we had a great fucking Thanksgiving and
I had this fucking bottle of Bourbon
that I brought. That was my
responsibility. When the fuck is my phone,
I got to give this thing shout out man.
And you know,
they say you can't judge a book
by, by it's fucking cover. Um,
I actually judged this bottle of just
by how cool the fucking bottle looked.
So let me scroll through my, it was
called angels and something or other,
by the way,
it rained like a motherfucker out here
and I have water collecting up on my roof.
Again, fucking cons. It's unbelievable.
It's just fucking, it's just,
it's just not even right.
So I got to get the third fucking people
out here to see if they know how to fix
it. Ah, God damn. And I thought I took
a picture of it. Nah, I got to find it.
Hang on a second. You know
what, me hit pause. I'll hit
pause. All right. I found it.
Angel's envy. It's a
Kentucky Bourbon. God Damn,
it was that delicious.
And I'm me and two other people.
We finished the bottle and uh, I
dunno, I got like two, my last one.
And I was just like, you
know what? I think this, uh,
I think it's time for me to shut it down.
You know,
maybe once in a while that drink and just
gets a little bit too fucking far and
then I just shut it down. So I walked
away cold Turkey, thanksgiving night,
cold Turkey. I fucking
walked away from it. And um,
you know,
not gonna lie to you. I miss
it. It's only been four days.
I'm still thinking about you sending
it letters and shit. Um, yeah,
I'm just going to shut it
down probably until, um,
I'd say maybe the Rose Bowl New Year's
day or whatever. I already got it,
shut it down and get a fucking kid
coming so it's over. You know what,
you know what people, I gotta
be honest. I had a great run.
I got the stories, you
know, I spent a few,
a few hours in jail. I mean I've done,
you know, went to court. I had the whole,
you know,
had to apologize to people.
I had a very full experience with alcohol,
you know,
talk to some chicks that were way
out of my league. You know, I,
I did it. I had the whole thing, you know,
stayed on the outskirts of bar fights
to make sure that I didn't get pummeled.
So that's it. So anyways, um, believe
it or not, as bad as my cough sounds,
it's way better than it was
fucking yesterday. I was going to,
wasn't going to put you through that
shit. So anyways, so Sunday night, yeah,
smoked it on one of those
cigars and yesterday I woke up,
but just so was having a fucking coffin
fit. Granted I was already run down.
So yesterday, um, I didn't
do shit. I got to tell you,
that was like the greatest six
hours of my life, not doing shit.
But somewhere in that six hours after
the six hours I was going out of my
fucking mind. I don't know how you
guys do it, you know, not you guys.
Just whoever the fuck is out there that
just can just truly take a goddamn day
off I go fucking nuts. After six
hours was great. I laid there,
I watched like two,
three episodes of um,
Westworld getting caught up.
I'm up to like episode six,
I'm going to watch today.
Right.
And I'm loving that show.
Although he can't watch more than two
or three a day. It's just too much man.
It's like you just gotta be you.
It's a lot of shit going
on to kind of take it.
And then also having now doing my own
little show, that's only a half hour.
When I look at that show I just think of
like how fucking long did it take them
to do this?
And then I'm going to sit here and I'm
going to watch it in two days and then be
that douche going when season two
coming out. You know, it's like,
it's a fine bottle of wine and I'm
just going to Chug the thing, you know,
after the third glass, I'm not really
tasting it anymore cause I'm so hammered.
I might as well be drinking like fucking
red, white and Blue Beers. Some shit,
right. Just doesn't
seem right. So anyways,
that's what I did yesterday and um, I'm
feeling much better. Thank Christ. So,
um, by the way, today's November 29th,
which is the five year anniversary since
the passing of one of the funniest and
greatest people I ever met,
Patrice O'neil and speaking of which
there are still some tickets left for the,
uh, the fifth annual Patrice
O'Neal comedy benefit. Um,
all the proceeds after we pay for
the, uh, the venue, of course,
our only expense, um, you know,
it goes to all of his loved ones.
It's been a tremendous success.
And this year we have, we have, um,
let's get the whole lineup here
for God's sakes. For God's sakes.
We've got Leslie Jones, we've got
rich foss, we got Bobby Kelly,
Keith Robinson, Gary Gulman, Dan's soda,
so right. And myself. Um,
it's going to be another great year of,
um,
I'm just getting to see all those people,
you know,
I never get to see them anymore because
I'm always out here gigging on the road
or living out here in la, but pop up up
above. So, um, that's going to be, uh,
Tuesday,
February 21st at the New York City Center.
And um, you know, it's just a,
it's just a great event and um,
thank you to everybody who's come
to it in the past years and um,
you've guys have done a wonderful thing.
I'm keeping all his loved ones comfortable
and I'm very proud of that whole
charity thing because, um, you know,
as tragic as it was that he was gone,
I'm very proud of the fact that all of
his friends stepped up and that all of
his loved ones are comfortable cause I
know that that's what he would have been
concerned with. So with that, um,
I'm actually doing another benefit for
those. You can't make it to New York City.
If you're in the La area
and you would like to, um,
you'd like to help out on another benefit.
I have another buddy of mine that died.
So what happens when you get into your
forties, man, it's fucking brutal.
Is a couple of your buddies die too young
man, it's awful. This Guy Pete coming,
I started out with him in um, 1992, um,
did stand up with them from 92 to 99
and then he moved on to writing with
National Lampoon. He did some stuff for
the UFC. Just a great guy. Unfortunately
he had a heart attack a few weeks ago
and about a month ago. So, uh, Tuesday,
December 6th at the laugh factory,
I'll be doing a headlining set
there and I'm a bunch of pizzas,
friends from back in the day,
a bunch of comics.
We haven't all been on the same
show in forever. Probably 20 years.
We'll be going on, um,
earlier in the night. Uh,
it's going to be a great thing and a,
it's in memory of him. So there you go.
So enough with the friends of mine that
have passed away unfortunately. Um,
and let's talk about some
shit here. I fight. I got it.
Why I to give a shout out to fucking Nico
Rosberg what in his first Formula One
championship,
um,
the final few laps of that
race were amazing. Right?
For those of you who are not into it,
basically what the situation was,
Lewis Hamilton had won the last three.
Nico Rosberg had never won.
They both drive from
Mercedes. Okay. So Nico's,
the young upstart Lewis
is the grizzled vet,
even though they're both fucking young.
It was kind of like
days of thunder of both.
Both people look like fucking Tom
Cruise is basically it, right?
It's like too Tom, the old Tom
Cruise, right? Scientology,
Tom Cruise versus fucking,
um,
what was that movie that they will all in?
Whether they were the socials in the
greasers the fuck was that movie called?
I knew that one.
Okay.
God dammit. What was it
called? Matt Dillon was in it.
Emilio Estevez as Steph says,
uh,
the dirty dancing guy, roadhouse
guy. The karate kid was in it.
Tom Cruise was in it.
Who else was in that fucking movie?
Everybody was in that fucking movie.
Everybody like there was like nine people
in that fucking movie. They'd all went,
uh, see Thomas Howell, they all went
on to star and movies that made,
I would love to see how much
fucking box office, every,
every guy that started as a greaser in
that movie ended up making. You know,
he got to hate being the one fucking
grease or that didn't make it right.
That's when you just got to
look at yourself like, dude,
what the fuck everybody
in this ensemble cast?
I got to find out what it is
now. All right, Tom Cruise.
I am DB.
How do you spell Kruze Rung?
I somehow spelled it with to use a yos.
Tom fucking crows.
Toyos. All right. There he is. Smiling,
looking sort of normal, as
normal as he possibly can. Well,
what the outsiders,
the outsiders.
All right, here we go. Let's, let's
this, this is the fucking line up.
See Thomas how Matt Dillon,
Ralph Machio. Patrick Swayze.
Rob fucking low.
Emilio Estefan is Tom Cruise.
Okay.
All right. That alone right
there. One, three, four,
five,
six.
The first seven guys all
went on to star in movies.
Tom Cruise alone has done billions
in box office. Matt Dillon,
the amount of money he's
done, Ralph Macho, the fucking
karate kid, Patrick Swayze,
dirty dancing alone. Forget about ghost
when they were in the claymation class
and what he did. And he comes up
behind her and they go, oh wow.
The time of my love,
Whoopi Goldberg grabbing your tits.
I swear Emilio Estefan is right.
He was in stake out.
He was in fucking, uh, the breakfast club.
MMM.
He was in the cowboy movies, right. And
he played Billy the kid come, you know,
all these fucking people are,
and you've got a guy like Glen Withrow.
The fuck happened to him. Diane Lane. She
was in a bunt, Leif Garrett. Jesus Christ.
He sold a bunch of albums.
Tom Waits was in that fucking movie.
Then there was a William Smith who plays
the store clerk. You went by William,
if you went by will, you know,
could've been a whole different story.
So anyways, I didn't know
what the fuck I'm saying. Oh
yeah, so Nico Rosberg, right?
So here's the deal.
The way the points worked out was Lewis
Hamilton had the wind. The fucking race
provided Nico didn't crash. All right?
If Nico is gonna finish the race,
Louis had to win the race and Nico had
to become in fourth place or worse,
and then Louis would have won
his fourth in a row. Okay.
But a lot of three peat and
out there for not nobody.
Who the fuck does four in a row?
You never see that shit. Right?
So it comes down to the La.
All Nico had to do was finish in third
place and no matter what Lewis Hamilton
did, the shit was over. So you get
down to like five fucking laps to go.
Nico Rosberg, he's in third
place, he's a fucking lunatic.
He passes. And then it was a
red bull car. And all guys,
I love the guys who announced it.
They're always so fucking,
oh like whenever there's
a pass. Oh Jo. Oh God.
They're always doing that shit. It's
like, dude, do you have money in that car?
Is that your son in there?
I mean after reasonable watching
this shit is to see him crash.
It's like watching hockey,
half bits to watch the game.
The other half is to watch somebody beat
the fuck out of somebody. I want to,
I want to see somebody spin
around a little bit. You
know, I want to see a fender.
Right. So anyways, uh,
so it gets down to the last five laps.
Nico goes around,
whoever the fuck was in second place.
How can burger or fucking one of
those other guys are Timo Nikunen,
Timo, Salani. I don't know any of the
end of the year, the other drivers yet.
It's my first year watching it.
Right. He fucking passes the guy.
Now he's in second place. So now
Louis is like, what the fuck?
So Lewis Hamilton starts slowing down
trying to let the third and fourth cars
catch up, which they're doing. All
right. Now there are a fucking team.
They're on the same team.
So evidently,
yeah,
when the head dude and Mercedes, you
know, if you're on the Mercedes teams,
if you're a team,
calls you and tells you to do something.
He not supposed to disobey a direct order.
I'm telling you,
this is like top gun and fucking
days. The thunder, sorry. It's just a
little touch of a bowl of people, right?
So he gives look that they give Lewis
the direct order to go and Louis, uh,
you got to drive faster here.
Come on. We want to win this race.
And Louis just says,
he just says back into the radio on TV,
basically said, um, well, um,
I'm still in first place and I'm
comfortable with my current position,
basically.
Meaning like I'm not going to drive any
fucking faster and I'm good enough that
even if Nico's right on my ass, I know
he's not going to try to go around me,
you know,
risking crashing because he's got it.
So for the last five fucking lapse you,
I just on the edge of your fucking seat,
like is this guy in third place
going to go around Nico Rosberg um,
he didn't Lewis Hamilton
disobeying a direct order.
I believe Robert Duvall came out in the
end and started screaming at somebody.
I can't remember, but, um, it
was kind of funny, like whenever,
like they're both on the podium,
which was almost every race this year.
Nico and Louis like wouldn't even look
at each other. It was fucking like,
oh my God, I'm not even talking
to you right now. I'm like,
so like not even talking to you right now.
Like it was that whole fucking energy.
So when Nico,
when's the thing,
they actually shook hands and there was
some fucking clown interview and I'm
going, oh, I kind of blocked the shot.
Can you guys do that again? It was great.
And then they just sort of begrudgingly
shook hands or whatever and the guy just
goes, oh, that's great. It's a, it's
all good again, or something like that.
It's like, dude, it's very far
from all good again. So, um,
I believe the season starts up again,
either the end of March
or the beginning of April,
and I jumped on this year after they
raced in Monaco and I had a great time
fucking watching it.
And I actually started to think of the
sheer amount of fucking money it must
cost to have a Goddamn to
run a Formula One team.
I can't imagine how much fucking money
you got to ship that car around the
fucking world like nine times.
And you know,
you've got a couple of other
cars you've got to bring with it.
It's got to cost you $1 billion.
It has to, does it bill?
Have you ever tried to ship even your
fucking Prius to Connecticut now?
So then you really don't know how much
it costs. Ah, you got me. Whatever.
I know it's got to cost a lot
of fucking money there, right?
So anyways, anybody watch
Ohio State, Michigan? I know
this is kind of old games,
but I don't give a fuck.
Did you guys watch that?
It's one of the best games I've seen
between those two in a long fucking time.
And, um, Michigan just kept
fucking up when they got the ball.
They had the Goddamn game one. Do you
notice how, what's his face there?
The whatever reason,
I can never remember their last name.
The fucking coach and Michigan.
Jim Harbaugh.
Do you notice he was wearing
the woody Hayes glasses?
I actually had a theory that if they won,
he was going to take the glasses off on
their fucking logo on the 50 yard line
and steps stomp on him. You know,
like after Jewish people get married,
they step on the fucking glass. He was
going to do that with the fucking his,
his woody Hayes glasses. And I loved
that he called out the referee and,
and all that shit.
You know,
I'm not saying I 100% agreed with them
and all that shit, but uh, you know,
I thought they got to call
right on their first down.
I stood up too when I saw a
live action. It was like, yeah.
And then I saw a fuck. He got it.
I thought he got it. Anyways. Um,
but all my Michigan Buddies,
they were all texting me.
That was a home job and all this type
of shit. So who do you like guys?
It's probably going to be
Alabama, right? That had a nice,
had an easy time with fucking Auburn.
She,
the kicker for Auburn,
he grew up in an Alabama family
roll tide family in Alabama.
Didn't give him a scholarship. So he, he,
he goes to fucking Auburn now and his
grandfather calls him turncoat fucking
lunatics down there. Right? Scary
Danielson. The whole gang keeps going.
It was turncoat kicking it for three.
I didn't think this podcast
is remotely funny, but maybe,
maybe just laughing at me. Coughing
up a fucking lung here. Um,
anyway,
so it's going to be Alabama
and I'm going to say it's going to be
Ohio state for the championship and he has
old Billy red face. Having only watched
about 15 college games this year,
having never played beyond the third
grade level. This is my prediction.
All right. Organized. Anyways,
I played enough pickup football for the
first time ever throw up my back was
playing fucking football and uh,
it's never been the same, you know?
No,
it's not the first time.
First Time was when that kid put me in
the figure four leg lock and fourth grade
outdoor recess.
That's the first time I threw it out.
The next time was playing football.
And then the third time was
another wrestling thing.
I tried to lift my younger
brother up over my head,
like Tony Atlas and the the
upper third of my spine folded.
It felt like, and uh, you
know, that's giving me problems
ever since then. You know,
it's probably why I leaned on the mic
stuff. Anyways, plowing ahead here.
I think it's going to be, it's going
to be fucking Ohio state, Alabama.
Obviously I'm picking the number
one and two teams and I think, uh,
Alabama Beats Ohio state this time simply
because I thought Ohio state had a lot
of problems with debt defense
there in Michigan. Um,
and I think Alabama's defense is even
better and Alabama's offense is not going
to make the fucking mistakes that
Michigan's, um, offense made.
You know,
you don't watch an Alabama team and they
fumble a fucking snap on the one yard
line. They just don't do shit
like that. You know what I mean?
Cause what's his face? Nick
Saban, that Luna ticket,
he probably fucking waterboard
you. How angry it dude. You know,
that guy makes me feel good about
my anger when I see that guy.
I was joking about this. I did, uh,
Jeff's a as podcast and we
will fucking joking about,
my favorite fucking thing to do is to
watch Alabama going in like down by seven
at halftime.
I love when the halftime report,
it comes up and starts
talking to Nick Saban and the,
the look of fucking anger on his face.
All he wants to do is go into the locker
room and call everybody's mother a cunt
that's wearing his uniform, right? And,
but he's got to sit there and talk to
some chicken. The sidelight go. I like,
so why do you think it is
your dad by eight to me?
I said, just sit there. You know,
he just wants to slap the wig right off
her fucking head. But he doesn't do it.
He doesn't know it.
He sits there with his fucking,
I dunno what it is on his head,
you know,
he makes Donald Trump look like fucking a
Fabio.
I'm trying to think of
somebody who has good here.
Who the fuck he been has good hair and
you never even know anymore, right?
Everybody goes around, they get, they
get the troops from the back, you know,
peeling. But the potatoes get put
out right up on the front line.
Now there's now what they do.
Then everybody goes swimming and nobody
knows what's going on, right? Tell you.
It takes a real man like myself to
walk around looking like Charlie Brown.
I'm telling you. Redheaded,
Charlie Brown. Um. Anyways,
let's read some advertising
here for this week, everybody.
Let's see what we got here on the docket.
How about those Bruins?
Finally winning the game, right? Second,
I started watching and they go into
a three game fucking skin. Okay?
Just to let you know what a big boat.
A big,
you cannot put a price
on what does it dino,
Ciara brings to this Boston Bruin
defense. All right, a frame bridge.
All right.
If you previously listened to this show,
you've heard me talk about
frame bridge. Hey, relax. Okay?
Some people fast forward through
these things that they made.
They make it super easy and affordable
to cuss to custom frame your favorite
things. You got a nice Dick Pic.
Ah, they got the frame for you.
I'm from art and prints and posters
to the photos on your phone.
They're expert team handcrafts.
Each custom frame here in
the u s handcrafts it. I
thought they just measured it.
They hand crafted steak and
we'll send it to you and in days,
not weeks or months. All right? That's
why you're going to love frame bridge.
That's why sending a custom frame
picture with frame page is the Goto gift.
This holiday season, that's a great
gift. You don't have any fucking money.
Just frame a cell phone picture,
you and the other person.
Just be right like friends or smile.
Put a little Emoji on it.
It's just beautiful.
These guys are going to save you
a ton of money in a few minutes.
You can build an order, a thoughtful
personal gift on frame, bridge,
dotcoms website or
straight from your phone.
They're expert team will handcrafted
custom frame or just measure it,
picture of frame that fucking fits it
right for your picture and we'll drive it
straight teeth to you
or someone on your list.
And the best part frame bridge starts
at just $39 in shipping is free.
Yeah,
in a few minutes you can
create a meaningful custom
gift for everyone on your
list. A picture of your
sibling for you. Uh, you went,
you guys got to do for Christmas.
Just get a fucking,
just take a selfie of yourself and
then send it to frame bridge and get a
handcrafted photo and just,
you know, send it to everybody.
My gift to all of you,
this holiday season is a
picture of me this way,
even though when I'm not there,
I can always be there. All right,
pick the perfect frame it
frame bitch, stop, calm.
You can preview your item in all their
frame styles. Then upload a picture.
You can even frame an Instagram photo,
the talent experts at frame bridge.
We'll print and frame your item and ship
it straight to you or your loved one.
Your gift arrives in days completely
ready to hang and includes a handwritten
gift.
Nope.
That frame bridge help you
win the holidays with a
thoughtful gift. That's easy.
Right now you are you going to do is go
to frame bridge.com and use the promo
code [inaudible]. You'll save 15%
off your first order. Now remember,
place your orders by December 18th
to ensure delivery by Christmas.
That's Promo Code Burr holiday
deadline is December 18th okay,
next up on the docket on it.
Joe Rogan's company on
it has a new product.
It's called emulsified MCT oil.
The fuck is that MCT oils,
one of the fastest sources of clean
fuel for the body and the brain.
It's one of the best ways to power up
your performance or kickstart a weight
management program.
There's a little,
there are lots of MCT oil brands
out there. I didn't know that,
but there is none like emulsified
MCT oil from Onnit available in three
delicious flavors. Coconut,
Vanilla and strawberry.
Oh my DNA. Coconut head, Fenella skin
emulsified.
MCT oil makes mixes like a cream easily
in your more like Gary Sheffield.
You Rub it on your arms and your morning
coffee without the need for a blender.
No mess, no cleanup. You can even mix
it into your favorite foods right now.
If you go to [inaudible] dot
com slash bill you can get on,
it's emulsified MCT oil for 12% off.
That's on it.com did I just girl bill
to get emulsified slash bill to get
emulsified MCT oil for
12% off for any reason.
If you don't like it, they'll give you
your money back. No questions asked.
They're just mean muggy as you walk out
the store, they're all fucking checked.
Got those neck muscles. You know like
they could shrug their shoulders for days.
Why? Because they're taking
their emulsified MCT oil.
You've got nothing to lose.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bill now and get on it. Oh wait,
how many more of these motherfuckers?
We've got three more.
Let's get the first three out of the way.
What do you say? Tipsy elves. Every one.
It's just not a porn out,
by the way. Tipsy elves.
Have you ever wanted to take advantage
of an Elf but it wasn't drunk enough?
Welcome to tipsy elves.
Everyone.
Everyone needs an ugly Christmas
sweater this time of year.
Okay.
Um, if you want bragging rights
for the most talked about sweater,
your Christmas parties.
Listen Up.
Talk about your tipsy elves sweater and
other products you saw on this website.
Oh God. This is like a fucking
hipster website. Um Oh,
that's just great.
That's so bad. It's good.
A tipsy elves has hundreds of Christmas
sweaters designs that are nothing like
you've seen before.
They're not for the faint of heart.
Check out the all new 2016 sweaters.
You won't find them anywhere else.
Tipsy elves.
Sweaters are all about fun,
but are serious on
quality and construction.
When you're shopping
for your ugly sweater,
checkout the other holiday and collegiate
attire for yourself or is it gift like
adult onesies?
Yeah.
What does that feed pajamas with?
Like a dick hole cutout. Huh?
You got like a fucking,
what do they call that?
When the chicks at the truck
stop and it's just the hall.
The Guy Sticks a glory hole.
You've got a glory hole in the front.
You know they're made out of wood.
They're wood pajamas,
and you just stick your Dick
through the fucking the knocked out.
Not In the word I for men, interactive
sweaters, beer pong, corn hall,
and Christmas suits. I didn't want
to know what that is for women.
Holiday legging sweater
dresses and pajamas.
Okay.
Right now my listeners get 20% off tipsy
elves.com on anything they order on
their site shop now,
so you have the best selection to
choose from and you have the t eh,
you have it in time for your
ugly Christmas sweater party.
Go to tipsy elves.com enter my code Burr
at checkout to get 20% off a sitewide
discounts.
That's tipsy elves.com/ [inaudible] right?
No tipsy elves.com and then my code burr.
All right.
Okay.
Are you kidding me? I still got three
more to go. All right. Fuck this dude.
Fuck this. Okay. Let's
plow ahead. Where are we?
32 minutes in. Was there anything
else I wanted to fucking talk about?
Uh, oh dude, I started going
through my shit cause I'm, I'm,
I'm selling my Prius,
right?
So I'm going back and I'm trying to
find the title to my car and of course I
can't find this fucking thing.
And I find the title to my wife's car,
to my car and my old truck.
And I also found a copy of a
title to this 88 Honda accord.
I had like fucking 15 years ago
I had the DX Lx,
the LX five speed manual transmission.
What a great fucking car that was.
God Damn it. I loved that car. Um,
I found a copy of that,
but nothing for the Prius and I gotta go
fucking to the DMV and get a copy of it
and all that bullshit. Um, ended
up getting rid of that shit.
Move on with my fucking life. Um, yeah.
Get a fucking God damn conference
call coming to Pune. 10 minutes.
I'll have to finish the rest of the
podcast later. I apologize. You know,
it's what it is. Patriots,
jets. Did you watch that?
How fucking awful that our defense look
in the first fucking half. Good Lord.
Um, I mean, I know were banged up
and everything, but uh, I don't know.
Remember that time when we traded Richard
Seymour long time ago in every Patriot
fan was like, dude, what
the fuck did we do that for?
And then the people who were
kind of paying attention
and we're like, well look,
it was a deal. Next year he's
going to be up for free agency.
He was going to ask for a zillion dollars
and we knew we weren't going to give
it to them and then we would
have gotten nothing for him.
So we traded him the year before I went
on this website and they showed all the
trickle down from that thing,
that trade,
um,
and all the players we got,
how we could be more aggressive because
of what we got from Richard Seymour.
I'm hoping the same thing is
that happened this year with a,
I didn't know if we traded Chen Chandler
Jones and we lost him to free agents,
free agency. But, uh, they're fucking
dude that we sent to Cleveland,
which I keep with Jamie Collins. Maybe
that'll turn into something, but, uh,
I dunno, it's unhealthy as we
are. I'm not, I'm not, I dunno,
I'm not giving up. I never came up. I'm
just saying, you know what the fuck.
It's the God damned jets.
They will fucking go and crazy
to every fucking play they made.
They were going fucking nuts.
You know,
like they just fucking like, that was
their playoff game, which I respected.
They fucking came to play. But
anyways, so this whole fucking weekend,
all I did was watch football and I,
and I was looking for that title and in
the process of looking for the title,
I cleaned up a bunch of my shit and I
was kind of thinking with a kid coming
along, um, I'm not going
to have time to do shit,
but life is going to keep hitting me.
So I want to know where
all my insurance forms are.
We're every fucking piece of legal
shit that I need. You know what I mean?
Like the lengthy tracking
number and all that.
I'm getting all of that
stuff organized and um,
I had all these fucking
shit that I held on to for,
I had like fucking my insurance auto
insurance contract from like 2007 until
now. And I'm like, it expires 12
months after you get it. Bill,
you've held under this shit for
nine years longer than you need to.
So I shredded a lot of shit,
but a underrated,
just finally going through your
office and just organizing everything.
I kinda know where like everything
is now. And uh, I want to,
I want to do that kind of
for everything that I have.
So when my kid comes here and then
take some marker out and draws all over
everything, I'll know where the fucking
insurance shit is. All right, let's,
let's read 'em. Let's read some, uh,
some questions here for the
week. Stan. Hope special is,
is somebody writing it about the
great. Doug Stanhope said, Hey,
bill used your promo code to sign up
for CSO so I could watch stand hopes new
special. I've heard nothing but
great things. He said, Holy Shit,
you're still my favorite bill,
but Stan hope is a genius.
Why do you guys always have to do that?
You still going to take the piss out
of me? I know. He's fucking tremendous.
You know, why can't you just say, this
guy's a great comedian. I'll dye it bell.
I it, but this guy over here. Yeah,
everybody in the Internet's got to
do that. If you have a good band,
someone's got to just sit there
and be like, dude, I love you guys,
but it's fucking Doug. Stan
Hope, man. He's a fucking,
I know he's a genius.
You didn't have to take the piss out
of me and he's fucking better than I am
fucking cunt. Um, he said, I
wish more people knew about them.
I felt the same way about you years ago
when you were just a comedy baby. Uh,
tell you people at Netflix
to give them the Chappelle
treatment. Uh, love you, man.
Um, yeah, I've heard nothing but
great shit about that. I'm sorry.
That's the last of the, the,
the Ricola eaten on the mic.
Kind of a fucking amateur am my, um,
all right, well what you're telling me,
every comedian has known about Doug Stan
hope since probably the late nineties.
And um, Doug is, um,
ever watched those cop movies.
You know, when you know that guy,
he always has to turn in his badge cause
he's doing shit outside the system,
but he's got a good heart and in the end
he arrest the bad guy and it's all good.
That's who Stan hope is.
Right.
But the entertainment industry
hasn't figured that out yet.
But eventually he will be standing on
their fucking city hall steps as they give
them the key to the city.
I'm hoping, but, um,
my rule with all of these guys is I don't
watch this standup special just cause
I can't have an hour and an hour and a
half of this shit floating around in my
head because it'll influence, you
know, I'm of two paranoid about that.
But my rule is that with all
these guys, Rogan, Stan Hope,
Louie Chappelle,
all of these guys that if they come
into a comedy club that I'm at and,
uh, they're going to go do a set, I
will watch them. That's how I do it.
But I don't watch their specials cause
I'm too paranoid about any sort of
overlap or whatever. But,
um, having said that,
every time Doug stand,
hope's specials come out always,
always, always for like three
to six months afterwards,
comics had just taken me aside and go,
dude,
have you seen Stan hopes new
fucking special? Um, yeah,
he's fucking incredible.
And um, I don't know. Well,
I dunno why. I Dunno. Why, what
it is about comics like that,
that they just,
uh,
I dunno if the industry
just won't give the same,
I don't,
you know what it is at the end of the
day where if you ever have a question
about an artist you like,
just imagine Doug Stan hope on TV
trying to sell your Ritz crackers. Okay.
How long could he talk about those
crackers before they would have a major
fucking pro? And I think that's
what it comes down to. All right?
There's the people that
are truly are the greats.
And then there's the people that are
really good, but they won't fucking,
you know,
they can sell a box of Ritz crackers.
That's what it kind of comes down to it.
Doug.
Stan hope is one of those fucking
guy is what makes them great.
So maybe that's what it is.
I liked that this guys like that.
You got to have the fucking row guys.
You know what I mean?
You can't have everybody just fucking
hanging out with a, I don't know,
Eddie show Biz, you know, at a fucking,
you know, in an election party.
You know what I mean? And
talking about issues, hi,
I'm fucking sandy sands, Sam cakes and
I'm here to talk about the fucking, uh,
the slaughter of baby seals
and all of that. You know,
that main stream, like, um,
step off your private jet.
Take the time to give a fuck for 20
minutes before you go back to yelling at
your personal assistant.
There's that level of uh,
connecting with people and then
there's what Stan hope does,
where he fucking goes, where they're
at. That guy is literally played,
I would say,
you know,
let's say there's 10,000
comedy clubs in this country.
He's played at least 9,998 of them.
That fucking guy has played as much
as I've done a bunch of [inaudible].
That guy has been fucking
everywhere and that's why,
that's why he's as good as he is, that
his work ethic, he's fucking prolific.
He's one of my favorites of all time.
So I wish I knew what the name of the
specialist maybe I can like go to look at.
I'll look that up. You know
what? I got to hit pause.
I got this fucking conference call.
I'll be right back.
And I'll also have the name of the
special. What do think about that?
And this will be like fucking like
an eighth of a second year life.
Just like those fucking millennials.
What? They're virtual reality glasses.
What's that over there in la,
which I fucking hate that commercial
where the kids are sitting there freaking
the fuck out. Like they don't
realize that it's not a real world.
And then the greedy corporate constant,
what do they got to do?
They've got to have the old curmudgeon
guy like me actually older than me.
And then what are you kids do?
And then he puts it on and then of
course he's completely enamored, right?
And now he's going to be into the shit.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Fuck those glasses.
I swear to God man,
like the amount of people that are going
to get mugged while they have those
fucking things on in public.
Cause I'll tell you right now,
these fucking kids are so God damn stupid.
They're wearing one of those and like on
a city bus and just fucking have it on
there.
You know what I mean?
It's like walking into why
Cornell's little fucking baskets
with what?
Cobra in there and you stick your head
in with your virtual reality glass
glasses and he can't see the snake
anymore because you're in fucking a middle
earth. Ah, the old man's coming out of me
this week. All right. Hang on a second.
All right. And I'm back just like that. An
hour of fucking conference calling. Huh?
Don't you wish you were me?
Is there anything better
than a conference call? Hey,
let's get on and make a
call and have a conference.
Everybody can talk and share ideas.
Have another hour your life go by that
you're never going to get back. All right.
You know, this is how old I am. You know
what's on my Christmas list this year?
You know it,
this pajamas,
I've had the same pair of fucking
pajamas for like, I don't,
I don't even know how long.
Like, I dunno, maybe, uh,
early two thousands, you
know, I'm trying to think.
All this shit that I've watched on TV and
these jam jams and they've just had it.
It's fucking over and
I've actually dropped.
Not even the hint I just demanded.
And you get to when you get to be my age,
cause no one gives a
shit about you anymore.
You can't ask for something for Christmas.
You got to start.
You got to make demands with like a
touch of a threat. Okay. I'm just saying,
okay, just throw, putting this out there,
but we'd be in everybody's best interest
if I've got some new pajamas this
Christmas. That's all I'm saying.
Okay. Huh? You like where you live in,
you liked it.
There better be some jam jams
under the fucking tree. Um,
anyways and then no matter what,
then you end up being wrong.
Like I had a fucking argument with my
wife this week about the way she fucking,
you know, stacks up the dishes in
the sink. You know what I mean?
I don't know if your wife does this shit,
but there'll be like a pot sitting in
the fucking sink and then they have a
plate. Right? What did they do?
They stick the plate on top of the thing
and then they take another bowl and
they stick it on top of the plate and
then he just got this leaning Tower of
Horse Shit and you fucking sink.
It's like,
why don't you put the plate underneath
the pot and then just see if the pot can
fit in a ball.
The ball can fit in the fucking pot and
then it takes like a third of this space.
You know, you haven't take a
door to that fucking Jane can,
you know, make, rather than
make it look like this,
10 weeks of fucking dishes here.
This is like two meals, you know,
one of those fucking,
one of those fucking dumb arguments
where you end up getting in your car and
driving away and then afterwards you're
just sitting there going, what the fuck?
I'm literally driving
down the street right now,
contemplating giving this woman
everything that I own in moving into a one
bedroom apartment over the way.
She stacks dishes in the sink.
But I'll tell you when you live with
somebody, it seems so fucking important.
All right, time off. Dear Billy
body, I think you're awesome.
Thank you.
And I have a crush on you and I'm,
hey,
hey, you go at that. The left term
was going to be, and I'm a dude.
I love that you take care of yourself
and are always striving to be better.
If this is great, you know what, if I
were you guys listening to this right now,
I would be highly suspect of whether or
not I actually wrote this in my husband
and I haven't seen you live yet.
And we want,
we want to this year. If you happen
to be coming back to Wisconsin,
well where the hell were you
a few months ago? You know,
when did you develop this crush in
October? I was there in September. Uh,
do you think you'll be touring as much
or will you be taking the year off to
spend time with your newborn?
Love you and I love Nia. Um,
oh, I'm totally going to be the absentee
father. I already have that worked out.
You know, we're going to be doing
like 56 weeks on the road. No,
obviously my schedule would
be a little bit different. Um,
be honest with you. I'd, I don't
know. Um, I do know, however, that,
um,
you know,
when I was getting ready to do my special
rather than doing one night in every
city, you know, when I did that little,
I played a smaller theater
and I spent a week in Durham,
like just Thursday, Friday,
Saturday. And I, it's,
it was so much more enjoyable way of
doing the road rather than doing one night
in Durham one night and fucking
Poughkeepsie one night here.
It just becomes a fucking thrash. And
when you were an older fellow like myself,
you know, I liked going to a
place, hanging out with the people,
seeing where they eat, going to a game.
That's how I always fucking did it.
So I'm going to try to do more of that.
And I was just in Madison and funny you
should bring up going back to Milwaukee.
Uh, uh, Wisconsin was, I haven't
been to Milwaukee and um,
well I guess it was October of, it's
amazing. I can always remember this.
It was like October of
2015 so it's been a,
we'll call it December at this
point. So it's been 14 months. So,
um,
definitely in 2017 not only will
I be coming back to Milwaukee,
uh,
I plan on spending like three,
four days there because that Milwaukee
had not only a great cigar bar,
it had the best fucking steam
of any place I've ever been to.
And it was at a hotel called the Pfister.
I swear to God,
it the hotel is called
the Pfister. It's P, f.
I. S. T. E. R. If you add Milwaukee,
dude, I'm telling you man, Milwaukee,
don't sleep on Milwaukee.
Great people, great food,
great fucking Lake Front
property for a song, right?
And the sickest fucking steam room
you're ever going to go in to,
you get your own private like lifestyles
of the rich and famous fucking, it's,
it's unbelievable. So, um, no,
when you get to be my fucking age,
that's the type of shit appealing to
you on the road. You know what I mean?
It's not like God, Dude,
you got to go to Miami.
They got all these hot chicks down there.
I'm a fucking creepy old married guy.
Where is there a steam room?
Listen to me. I got to Berkeley. Losis
okay.
I ain't got time for the
WHO was, um, anyways,
so yeah,
tonight I'm actually doing the Steve
Allen Theater and whenever the fuck they
calling it now, and I'm just
basically running my whole new hour.
I'm so fucking excited.
I've gotten past the whole mourning
period of missing my old jokes, um,
past the hole. Now I'm not as funny
as I was on stage. Now, you know,
I took all the bullets out of the gun.
I'm shooting fucking blanks up here. Um,
this is my favorite
fucking thing in the world.
I'm so excited tonight about the show.
Um,
and just seeing where it goes.
And I've got a couple of buddies of
mine coming down who were musicians,
so they're going to get to see that whole
fucking, because I already told them,
I was like, all right, you guys
want to come down. This is gonna.
This is gonna be the real deal.
This is not the old tried and true.
They're all right. Coping
with being single. Uh,
oh, I already liked this right here.
Hey Billy, master of fuck. It's,
um,
I've been single my entire life.
I'm into my later twenties
and still haven't found any
lady that I really hit it
off with. I've struggled with
being single for a long time,
but had been working through it.
I'm okay with it,
but I still have my dark moments.
My question to you is,
when you were single for all those years,
did you ever get lonely or feel alone?
Uh, did you ever think
you'd be single forever?
What helped you to endure through those
times and how did you cope with it?
Yes to all of that. Yup. As
I figured some things out,
I've been doing bucket lists, types of
stuff that helps me get through it. Yeah,
dude, that's a great thing
to do when you're single.
Go do all that shit you want to do cause
a, you know, you meet somebody else.
Yeah. You know, you
might not have the time.
This person says, I've gone to see
some of my favorite bands play live.
I've traveled a little and I've been
working towards finding a career path that
I really enjoy.
So I believe I'm doing some good things,
but I still have my days when I
suffer through it a little. Uh,
but I've learned to sit in that
pain for a bit and find good things.
Uh, saying something dumb at
work. Oh, that's the next one.
I thought that was the guy signing off
or the woman, whoever the fuck this is a,
all right. My question to you is,
you've been single all those years.
Did you ever get lonely or feel alone?
Here's the thing,
I was never lonely for the first,
I don't know how many years am I in life
until I had a girlfriend and then lost
my girlfriend. And then after that,
that's the first time I felt like, oh,
I don't have a chick.
It's weird.
Okay.
I didn't have my first serious
girlfriend till I was like 23,
something like that, 22,
23 years old. So I was fine
with being single. And that thing lasted
like, I dunno, like eight, nine months.
And uh,
I ended up breaking up with her and that
was right before I started doing stand
up. And, um,
I remember the first six
weeks of being like, fuck,
how long is it going to take for
me to get over this person? And um,
it's weird, man. Like getting
over a person, it's like,
it's like Quintin, the booze.
It's a habit. They're a
habit. You know what I mean?
I always call them at this time. Then
he got to fill up those fucking times.
But you just can't fill him up.
You of got to go through the mourning
of them not being there anymore and then
you start filling them up with other
stuff. But like, dude, I think travel,
seeing bands and everything,
the great thing is too,
the fact that you aren't lady,
the fact that you're single and you
feel alone is a very healthy thing.
You know what I mean?
Now,
if you were totally fucking single
and you didn't feel lonely at all,
well I guess maybe,
you know,
maybe you're just a fucking someone
who doesn't want to be with anybody.
That could also be because as long
as you're not out killing people,
you know what I mean? As long as you
don't feel the need to hunt your,
you're not feeling that.
And as long as you're all right
with whatever it is you're doing,
then you should be fine too. During your
fucking late twenties through, trust me,
someday you're going to be married,
you're going to have a fucking kid coming
like I got right now and you'll all of
a sudden all your drum
videos you thinking,
I'm going to guide you gotta
gotta get rid of those.
I got to get rid of all his shit.
I got to get rid of all of this stuff
and there's this feeling that I'm having
right now.
Will I ever played drums again?
But fortunately I married the coolest
woman ever so I just was able to sit down
with her.
This,
this might help you if you're afraid
to get in a relationship cause you feel
like you're going to
lose all of this stuff.
You just let the person you're
with know what's important.
I already said to my wife, I said,
listen, here's the deal. Like once a week.
Okay.
You pick a day,
once a week when this kid is not sleeping
through the night and you can just go
somewhere, get a massage or just
go someplace and fucking sleep.
Or I'll take the kid and go drive around.
I'll let you sleep for fucking hours and
hours, whatever the hell it is. Okay.
All you gotta do is let me keep playing
drums, taking drum lessons in that shit.
That'll be my spot thing.
Cause I don't really need to
sleep cause I'm a fucking lunatic.
And also I'll still get to do the
road twice a month and you know,
I'll use that time to sleep.
I'll do my shows at night and then I'll
go right to the hotel and I was sleep
till the fucking cats come home,
the cows come,
whatever the fucking animal is
and then I'll come back recharged,
you know what I mean?
But we,
we make sure that we kind of worked
that stuff out with each other. So, um,
if you're afraid to get in a relationship,
just know that there's a cool
people out there as long as you, uh,
I dunno. Yeah. You never hear me say this,
but women in general pretty cool if you
just tell him what the fucking deal is.
Um, but I have issues with
women. So even as I said that,
just picturing how many women just
went like, oh my God, yes.
That like, that annoyed me,
even though they were agreeing with me.
It's weird. I got a lot of fucking issues.
So, um, yeah, I definitely felt, I felt
like I was never going to meet the one.
I felt like there was something wrong
with me and all of this type of shit.
Just know this.
Every one of your friends that's in a
relationship is secretly envious of you,
even if they're with the right person.
That's how much fucking work it is.
You know, every once in a while, you
know, I look at fucking, um, you know,
I look at it, I'll look at a playboy
like Joe de Rosa and I'll be like,
God damn it, man. What the fuck did
he's got? He's getting always key skis,
living the life, you
know, but then, you know,
you come home and your wife make
some fucking cookies. You're like,
this is pretty cool too. All right,
saying something dumb. It works.
So what I was saying to this
person, you, you, you fine dude,
you're in your late twenties.
I'm
the same way that you have goals with um,
your career in bucket
list stuff should have,
she should have some goals about the
kind of person that you want to be with
like a women after you
actually do shit like that.
Women actually sit down and think
about the kind of, guys don't do that.
We just sort of Ping Pong and wrong. I'll
stick my fucking Dick in that. You know,
we're idiots. But if you
actually, you know, get a little
bill Bellacheck, you know,
see what's missing. You know, from
your half, see what you're looking for.
What do you want? You know, do
you want a woman that wants kids?
Do you want a woman that can cook a, your
traditional, do you want a career woman?
Like, what do you want? You
know, I can tell you right now,
if you want a woman that can cook,
we'll actually sit down and cook. Woo.
Tell you right now that's like a,
I dunno,
you know like every, once every,
I don't know how many years they,
they have that and that 1983 draft,
like women do not foe women's
do not be cooking anymore.
All this feminism shit. It's really
a sad thing. But men have, you know,
it's our fault because we
didn't put a value on it.
Great. I'm out there busting my ass. You
Ain't here pickling cucumbers, right.
Just gave him shit.
Making a meal for somebody who's one of
the nicest things she could have a do,
you know? But what happened?
How we talk, shit we gave,
we didn't give him a fucking respect him.
Now look up. They don't want to cook up.
Be Mothers.
They're out there running around Willy
Nilly wearing pantsuits running in,
running for president
of the United States.
I mean, you know that. That's a man job.
Okay.
You know,
the funniest fucking thing ever is
how sick you have to be to want to be
president. The fact that Hillary
Clinton is depressed right now,
that she didn't get a job where she was
going to have to put her head on the
pillow every night knowing she just
made a decision that bombs would just
dropped and possibly landed on
somebody's baby and she, she's,
she's depressed that she didn't get
that fucking job. It's unbelievable.
What do you think are pajamas look like?
She definitely has the fucking guy once,
right?
Like the flannel ones
wearing the pants suits.
Um, I liked the pant suits.
I don't know why everybody gave a shit
about it. And I always liked Rhoda,
you know, Rhoda, Mary Tyler Moore, they
fucking fill those things out, you know,
walking around with the little bungees
up against that Rayon. All right.
Say something dumb at work saying
something dumb at work. Okay.
What do we got here? Um, yeah. Fuck you
guys. Mind if I just do the last bit of,
you know what,
that's a country move.
I'll read this and then I'll do the
advertising. Hey Bill, longtime fan.
Probably listened to you too much. Once
again, you start with a compliment,
then you give me the old
fucking Shank to the kidney.
Longtime fan probably listened to you
too much. All right. Too. Too much.
When it's too much. That's, that's
two o's. All right. All right.
Here's my problem. I was
at, I was at Work Party,
I think you mean at a work party?
Talking to my colleagues.
I work as an RN in an ICU.
Okay.
That's a registered nurse in
an intensive care unit. Uh Huh.
I have some nurses in my
family. Uh, we have a new
to our unit higher joining us,
but she's worked as a
nurse for 25 years already.
My friends said she's joining my rotation.
I say out loud in my typical
bill blurp burn a inflection. Oh,
Jj [inaudible]. No. How Ge is
another old broad in our line there,
several colleagues heard this and now
every day is some new twist on my comment.
Some chirping is fine,
but half the unit is over 50.
I want some joke comment.
I don't want some Joe comment to
hope haunt me for years. Bill,
how do I get this to go away? Thanks. Um,
I would just say it with them. I, I just,
I wouldn't back off and I would just
keep doing the Archie bunker and she's
another little broad on a line there.
And then when they, they, yeah,
this lady to World and Oh God, all
of you with your menopause, the,
but you can't do that at work now.
You can't do that work now because
you're not making it a safe place.
This is a safe space.
Ugh.
Oh my God. That alone, that alone
gave Trump about 200,000 folks
fucking adults saying,
you're not making this a safe space.
I just fucking did.
They all have a meeting and they came
up with that fucking horrific that,
that what was the second choice?
I just don't understand that.
Uh, you know something, I
have to be honest with you.
I don't know how you get out of that.
And right there.
That's why I do what I do for a fucking
living because there's no way I could be
in that level of a childish fucking
environment that people, oh,
what did you mean about that?
What are,
what about how many fucking thoughts
have you had in your head today?
Your old fucking bag.
Then if they were publicized that you
would even still have a job as a nurse.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Okay.
Yeah, you don't, you know, just, just,
you know, women like sweets just coming,
just bake a fucking pie or some shit.
Anyways.
Um, I'm sorry, going through
that. I'm sorry you were
quoting me, but you know what?
You also kind of blamed
me a little bit there.
We say you listen to me too much or you,
you,
you were throwing a little bit of blame.
You want a little Peyton manning there.
We had protection issues as what
you just did to me there. Um,
I dunno how much just be, you're
still bringing that. Yeah,
he's still bringing that up.
You should have heard what I said
this morning or something like that.
I would just do that.
Um, it is kind of funny.
Who gives a shit?
Do you like the job but all depends on
how much you liked the job with her watch.
She's old. You're all old. I wouldn't fuck
any of you, you know. I Dunno. I Dunno.
I don't know how to get out of that.
Um,
if anybody has any suggestions tweeted
at me and I'll fucking retweet it.
Maybe this person follows me on
Twitter and you can help them out. Uh,
would it help if I know you are a man
or a woman? I have no idea. All right.
Dollar Shave Club. Um, I'm guessing a man.
Okay.
If you're a woman, you're the coolest
woman over that. You said that. No,
they're all broad here. All
right. Dollar Shave Club.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing,
affordable raises right to your door
every month so you can get a great shape.
But razors aren't the only
thing you need in the bathroom.
What about some shower stuff?
Huh?
What about when you wash
it off the old teeth?
It turns out dollar Shave
Club thought of that too.
They just came out with a
new line of shower products,
shampoo and body wash called the wanderer.
Well,
I'm the type of guy who
likes to wash his nuts.
The fragrances are unlike
anything on the market.
There's subtle and actually smell
like real natural ingredients.
There are a lot of body washes out there
that make you smell like a teenager.
This men and Cedar Wood bodywash is
amazing. It makes you smell incredible.
It's like you're eating an ice
cream next to the fireplace. Um,
you got to give it a try.
What the fuck is so great
about Mitt and Cedar Wood Body?
Are those two different ones?
I hope.
MMM.
Like you're fucking eaten. Ice Cream over
Ron Burgundy's house, rich Mahogany. Uh,
you got to give it a try.
Once you're in the club,
you'll see the products are amazing.
The service is world class.
There's no long term commitments,
no hidden fees,
and you can cancel whenever you want.
And Best of all,
they're giving away a one month trial
of any one of their fucking ray for a
dollar with free shipping. And after
that, it's just a few bucks a month.
Get your online dollar
trial@dollarshaveclub.com
slash burr that's dollar shave
club.com/burr oh who's
next? Two more to go. Oh.
MVMT movement watches pronounced movement
was founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank.
The watchmaker's goal is to change the
way consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices with
over 500,000 watches sold to customers
and 160 plus countries around the fucking
world movement watches has solidified
itself as the world's fastest growing
watch company. Alright,
a holiday thought status,
please be conversational. Choose one
and make this your own. All right,
I'm going to choose this one.
We get it.
Fuckos holiday shopping
can be fucking had.
This is me making my own.
I just say fucking Boston accent,
but thanks to movement watches all
that gift giving horseshit anxiety can
disappear with the press of the button.
These watches make the perfect purchase
for just about any person in your life.
Guy Or girl. I remember they just
start at 95 bucks. You know what,
even if you don't like somebody
spending 95 bucks is too much money.
Only get this for people that you
care about. You know what I mean?
Everybody else, she can get a
fucking bumper sticker. All right.
Get 15% off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to movement
watches.com/burr this watch has
a really clean design. All right?
Seriously.
Evidently I've been getting compliments
on the one that I don't wear ever since
I put it on. Now is the time to step
up your watch game. Go to movement,
watches.com/burr join the movement.
Get a $95 watch for 500 bucks.
Style $500 watch for 95 bucks today.
Lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com everybody.
Oh Jesus. Satan naked coming here
for all the good questions out there.
He's a saint,
but he doesn't care about Muslims.
Jews are fucking a Buddhist people,
right? What about all those,
uh, aboriginals? Whatever
the fuck they worship, Huh?
How come Santa Claus doesn't go to them?
You know why? Cause they'd be like,
oh my God,
it's another white man.
And they fucking put a poison dart
and it serves them right. You know,
it served them right. Even though he
didn't do anything. He'd be a martyr.
You know, it's big stupid red
suit, lean face down in it, right?
stamps.com with the holidays almost.
I'm surprised that government has never
tried to set up Santa Claus by sending
them into some area with
his indigenous people.
Just set them up for a fight the way
we did when we took over this fucking
country.
You know,
so we could justify the genocide of those
wonderful people that when they killed
a squirrel, they used all of it.
Unlike us. What do we do? Huh?
Through the inside of the fucking want
Brent and then use the rest is a hat for
what is a goof? stamps.com
everybody, white people,
the Frat boys of people.
Uh, sorry. stamps.com. Um,
with the holidays almost here, you don't
have time to go to the post office.
Well you do,
but who the fuck wants to go?
It will be packed with everyone
mailing holiday gifts and packages. So,
so do what I do.
Do what I do.
Use stamps.com instead with stamps.com
you can void all the hassle,
man of going to the post office
during the busy holiday season,
buying print official us postage,
using your own computer or printer,
print the postage for any letter
or package the instance you needed.
Then the mailman picks up. You never
have to go to the post office again.
It's a fucking dream.
I use stamps.com whenever I'm
sending out any of my posters,
anytime I'm selling some shit
at the end of a fucking show,
anytime I think to myself,
you know what? I haven't,
I haven't Shaked enough sweaty
fucking palms of complete strangers.
You know what I mean?
I want to feel that warm arm pit of a
taller person as they put their arm around
me, sitting right on my shoulder,
seeping into my fucking buttoned out.
That's when I send out all my posters.
Everybody you can print the
postage and all that shit.
Then the mailman picks it up. All right.
Right now. Uh, I can do, you're better.
I can get you an even better offer
than what's on the home page.
Sign up for stamps.com right
now and use my last name,
bird to get a four week trial plus $110
bonus offer that includes postage and a
digital scale.
Go to stamps.com.
Click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinberlinstamps.com
enter
burn.
Okay, it's over. All right, let's,
let's finish off the rest of
these here. Oh, key dokie.
Fun Times in Syria.
Billy the cunt.
It's Martin from Sweden. Thank you
for this podcast. No worries. Uh,
it's been more than 10 years since I was
almost raped in Syria. What the fuck?
Although time passes,
the story seems to never get old.
All right.
You know, I, I, you really just going to
fuck with me on this God damn level here.
Am I supposed to believe this is true?
How time flies? It's like you're,
you're looking back fondly on this.
This is weird.
I was 17 when me and my class
went on a school trip to Syria,
puts in parentheses, Middle East.
Go Fuck yourself, Jason. I know,
I know American. I know
we're serious. All right.
One day all of my classmates
were out snorkeling.
I stayed in the hostel
bed because I had a fever.
Two aspirins later I found myself
out looking for my class in Sana like
temperatures with a foolish mindset.
My blonde, blue eyed nature,
fig figured the aspirin
had cured my fever.
So I was in quite good spirits for about
seven miles of searching for the other
Swedes. This is creeping me out. Now.
The fever was kicking back
and in at this point, uh,
and I'd given up my
endeavors of snorkeling.
I didn't know where I was or how to
get back to my hostel. At that moment,
a taxi pulled over. The driver
asked if I wanted to get a lift.
I said I didn't have any money to offer,
but he insisted that no money was needed
for the ride. Oh, Jesus is right. Yes.
High fever and good amounts of gullibility
led me to step into the cab and off
we went. Hi, welcome to Siri. The
taxi guy said, you are very beautiful.
I didn't want to be rude, so
I said, thanks back at him.
Then he asked me if I liked women.
Sure.
I replied that he asked if I
liked big women share. I said,
he said, ah, you like big because
same with your Dick.
He said,
what? At this point I regretted
getting to the what the fuck? Ah,
you like big because same
with your Dick. He said, okay.
I thought this was a woman, so it's a guy
and others, dude. Oh Jesus. Here we go.
At this point,
I regret getting to the taxi very much
in the moment after he was reaching for
my package while he was driving,
oh two that's,
oh you in the front seat.
That's when you got to do, what was
that fucking Schwartzenegger movie?
Or he gets on the plane with that guy
and he pretends to tie his shoe when he
comes up with the elbow,
a death and drives this spine of his
nose into his brain and then puts his
little fucking a Tommy Bahama ad over
his face and he goes, don't disturb him.
He's dead tired. That's what you
needed to do was that rod deal.
I think he needed to go rod
deal there anyways. I say,
no stop. I said, but the tracks,
he driver was very persistent.
He wondered why he couldn't touch my
penis. Like I owed him the right to do so.
I was feeling extremely vulnerable.
Being a teenager foreigner and
having a high fever and all.
I shouted at him to stop the
car, but he kept on going, dude,
you got to start going Dave.
The Hammer Schultes here. Right?
You got to fuck. And he got to start
swinging, man. Uh, but he kept on going.
I thought about jumping out of the car,
but I was, it was going way too fast.
I also didn't want to start a fight
and risk crashing the car. Ah,
Jesus. At some point, dude, you got to
pick your poison. Did it have airbags?
Picture pictures of Taliban
rape Cade's with pulp fiction.
Kim's suits and gag balls was entering
my mind as the taxi car continued to
drive on without any intent to pull over.
This is really happening.
Oh my Lord.
I thought to myself,
luckily we came to a traffic light and
I managed to get out of the car and on
the pavement. I started running
when I heard him screaming at me.
One Syrian pounds,
Mr Oh God.
Now you're going to get paid for forget.
You got to pay him from
moving less than you.
I got over the experience pretty soon.
[inaudible] have not affected
my life to any extent.
No fucking way.
People sometimes want me to tell the
almost raped story and given pressures of
the taxi driver.
I can't help to think how of unfunny it
would be if I were a girl almost getting
raped in Syria. Yeah, but you're
a guy so it's fucking hell.
Everything that happens to a guy's
hilarious. Nobody gives a shit.
My question to you is,
why is this kind of a,
why is this story kind of funny if it
happened to men but awful in every way,
if it happened to a woman, you're thoughts
on that after you go fuck yourself.
PSA hide a lovely new,
um,
this is why it's funny because
you're able to fight them off.
It's a guy with an accent grabbing
your Dick when you tell this story. I,
my friend, my friend, just like your Dick
Beep beep, right? It's just hilarious.
I remember one night we were
down in the comedy cellar.
We were all telling stories
about getting molested as kids.
And it was one of the
funniest nights I've ever had.
It was so fucking Cathartic and
we would just cry and laughing.
And I remember all the comics
where, you know, I dunno,
had a different upbringing.
We're looking at it like it was fucked up,
but it was fucking hilarious to me.
Um, and if you told me this story,
I would be laughing my ass off.
It's still knowing that you,
you probably have some sort of fucking
issue and all depends. It all depends.
You know, if that was the first person
that ever touched you, you know,
no girl ever.
He gave you a hand job.
The fact that it was the first
guy that ever did it, you know,
his Harry fucking hand coming over, you
know, they could possibly fuck you up,
but you know, okay, he had a little bit
of sexual activity. Maybe it doesn't,
you know, it's kind of like, you know,
if you're a relief pitcher and you,
you got to, he got some saves on your
belt. You let up a home run. Yeah,
give me another fucking ball. But if
that's your first fucking pitch, I mean,
that could fuck with. Yeah.
Um, why is it not funny?
Uh, when it happens to a woman's a same
reason why it's like watching a guy get
punched in the head is fucking funny.
You know, if he was like talking shit,
it's fucking funny. You know what I
mean? But like, you know, kids, women,
animals like this, just never anything
funny about watching them get abused.
But there's just something
hilarious about guys.
I would say the reason why you get having
your Dick grabbed and getting molested
is funny is the same reason why the
three stooges is funny. You know?
Imagine the three stooges,
if it was women grabbing each other
by the hair and slapping each other,
the faith, maybe that'd be a little funny.
I Dunno. It's just like a guy thing.
We like slapstick and there's
just something funny about
him grabbing your fuck
stick in some car and then he charged
one Syrian pounds,
you know.
Well it really comes down to is I
imagined being gay is not accepted even
remotely in serious.
So this guy thought like all right,
even if this doesn't go
down or if it does go down,
this story leaves this country
and goes back to Sweden. Uh,
so in the way I'm going to say the
cab driver was the victim and not you.
And stop being so selfish.
Now I'm fucking with you.
I'm sorry that happened to
you. Um, well you do. I mean,
I mean you were kind of asking for, cause
you were on cold medication. You know,
I'm going to blame the victim here.
Well, I mean, what were you wearing? Um,
I dunno dude. That's one of the more, uh,
I want to say that's one of the more
fucked up stories I've ever heard. But uh,
yeah, that, that's just goes into that
file. I've heard enough of those ones. Um,
yeah, that's why it's not funny. Um,
so I would actually say
that you are fucked up.
There's no way you're not fucked up cause
that happened to you. And there's, um,
there's that feeling where it's just like,
why is that funny when that happens to
a guy and then you feel like you can't
fucking a, that you should
should just, yeah. You know,
I'm over it. Like why would,
that's a horrific fucking
thing that happened to you.
And I'm even like over the whole thing,
cause it's a guy like, hey, you know,
fucking shake it off, shake it off.
And that's part of growing up.
It's always meet you have a paper
route or something like that.
There'll be some Weirdo come
in at your junk at some point.
But that's just how it is. I remember
when that fucking, I'm that lady.
Cut The dude's Dick off and put it in
the garbage disposal. One of those shows.
It's not the view. I think
it's the talk, the Asian Lady,
she was reading it and as she was reading
the details, they're all snickering,
laughing.
Okay.
And I remember the bid I was doing one
of some guy cut a woman's tiddy off and
threw in the garbage disposal.
I mean,
they would have done a week long special
on that and they would have tried to
help the lady out raise some money to get
her a prosthetic. You know what I mean?
So a broad wouldn't be all lopsided.
That's what the fuck they do.
But it happens to a guy.
It's just fucking hilarious.
And I also think that that's
why guys are so fucking funny.
Yeah.
You know, cause uh, you know,
if a woman gets molested, it's a tragedy.
If it happens to a guy, it's a sketch.
We really don't have any options.
You just got to shake it off, man.
You know, having said all that,
dude, I'm sorry that happened to you.
I'm sure you're emotionally
fucked up about it.
But I would love to hear that story one
time cause I want to hear you imitating
the guy, you know, and then listen to
everybody get interrupted. So wait,
how fast were you going dude?
You could jump on in the car.
He's grabbing it day and then
everybody be laugh ago. Yeah,
but if you jumped out then he'd
be like holding onto your Dick.
Like Steve has happened, the
car half part of the car, right.
Stretching out your deck,
you know,
then you have one of those needle dicks
cause it's not going to give you any
more girth.
He's just going to weed out.
That's what the whole
fucking thing would be.
And then all your friends would
laugh and say that you wanted it.
You know what I mean? Why don't you
sit in the back like a normal person?
Why did you sit up front?
You know,
that's what guys would do and
they would laugh. You know,
you'd just laugh your way through it.
So anyways,
I guess I'm going to stop there on the,
uh,
I can't, let's stop on
something positive. Once again,
I have two benefits that are coming up
to two friends of mine that are no longer
here. Um, Pete Coming, um,
memorial is going to be December
6th at the laugh factory.
I will tweet that link
and the Patrice O'Neal,
the five year anniversary of
his passing is today. And um,
the one truly positive thing that came
out of that is we get to remember him and
we get to see our friends and we get
to raise some money for his loved ones
every year.
And it's going to be February 21st a
Tuesday 2017 at the New York City Center.
Um, thank you to all who, uh, take the
time to check it out and buy some tickets.
It means the world to me. That's it.
Go fuck yourselves. Oh, by the way,
if you want to donate to this podcast,
uh, and not have to give any money,
if you're doing some
Christmas shopping on Amazon,
go to [inaudible] Dot com first
click on the podcast page.
He click on the Amazon link. It
doesn't cost you any, any extra money.
I just get credit for driving traffic
there. If you want to do it, I get it.
If you don't, I understand. That's it.
Go fuck yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday.